[Musique]
à
bonsoir à tous
est-ce que vous allez bien ce soir ce
que vous allez bien ce soir on voit pas
pour motiver ce que je suis en mode
stress donc ce soir je vais vous parler
de crottes bolschwing donc on essaie
dollar offert un peu avec le lac sans
octroi de chewing donc avant toute chose
j'aimerais savoir qui dans la salle est
déjà familier avec cet anglicisme donc
levé la main si des gens connaissent un
petit peu je pose cette question
personnellement c'est qu'à chaque fois
que j'en parle à des gens ils sont en
mode c'est quoi ça c'est tout à fait
normal et il ya même deux ans un peu en
arrière mais je connaissais pas du tout
ce concept cela et c'est parti d'une
question qu'un ami m'a posé donc on va
revenir un petit peu deux en arrière
c'est un soir d'été on faisait un
barbecue donc toutes les conditions
étaient réunies pour passer une superbe
soirée comme on aime à montpellier
température parfaite lors aux emmy
offrait quelques heures avant le
barbecue à la bonne température
il ya un beau filet mignon de porc
badigeonner de moutarde de dijon bien
sûr ce que pour tout vous dire mon ami
et bourguignons avec qui faisait le
barbecue donc c'était parfait et au
moment de poser la viande sur le grill
ils me posent la fameuse question il me
dit et clément tu sais d'où elle vient
cette viande et moi je réponds bah oui
du supermarché justement pourquoi faits
mais n'ont pas d'enfant ça mais plutôt
tu sais d'où elle vient dans quel pays
ça a été élevé dans quelles conditions
ce que c'était sûr du caillebotis sur de
la paille en plein air est ce qu'un
producteur hier ça et là gros blanc
j'étais juste incapable de lui répondre
c'est quand même fou de ne pas savoir ce
que l'on mange dans son assiette
du coup la soirée s'est bien passé on a
bien mangé
enfin parfait et puis quelques jours
après eh ben c'est cette histoire nous
rester en tête et du cou après les cours
on a décidé de voilà de chercher un
petit peu d'où venait vraiment nous dit
on et le constat était rapidement clair
si on prend l'exemple de l'élevage de
porcs
95% de l'élevage aujourd'hui s'effectue
sur caillebotis dans des bâtiments mais
c'est aussi les mêmes pratiques en
europe et dans le monde entier
on appelle ça l'élevage intensif donc là
je pense que tout le monde connaît ce
que c'est l'élevage intensif pour ça je
vais pas en argumenté pendant 10 15
minutes
mais si on prend rapidement les choses
c'est des porcelets qui sont retirés de
leur mère au bout de trois quatre
semaines non qui sont pas sevrés
ensuite ils sont mis avec d'autres ports
donc sont plus en fratrie qui sont
dédiés à l'engraissement donc là ça va
développer du stress des conflits et des
maladies et surtout dès leurs premières
semaines de vie aux porcelets on va soit
coupé ou me les leurs dans on va couper
lors que et pour les mâles et bon balle
et castrés et tout ça à vivre bien sûr
y'a pas d'anesthésiant et en plus de ça
pour pallier aux pathologies de
l'élevage intensif on va donner des
compléments vitaminiques au port donc
vaut mieux mais pas savoir ce qu'elle
n'aurait complément et en plus on va
injecter et ben des antibiotiques pour
éviter la propagation de maladies
donc on est tous d'accord on dire ben à
ce moment là les portes sont pas conseil
comme des animaux mais plus comme une
vulgaire marchandise ou le mot c'est
rendement rendement rendement en portant
un simple numéro on en est quand même
loin des pubs où on voit des porcs dans
bad et dans les prés roulant dans la
bouche pour ça c'est du feq et du coup
plus je m'intéressais à cette histoire
est plus des souvenirs mon enfance rien
passer et je vous rappelle quand j'étais
plus jeune
bon il ya pas si longtemps quand j'étais
plus jeune j'allais souvent à la
campagne chez mes grands-parents et je
l'adoré ça c'est pourquoi parce que tout
ce qu'il y avait autour de moi étaient
naturels et on avait l'habitude une fois
par an d'aller chez le producteur
à côté qui levait des porcs dans son
prix et on se cotise est en famille avec
des amis et on lui en acheter un du coup
le producteur il s'occupait les levées
de l'engraisser de le transformer et
apprennent on est récupéré la viande
const hockey après ensuite dans le
congélateur donc on en avait pour
plusieurs mois il ya même certains
morceaux de viande qui est pas le temps
d de congé pour revenir si mon ami m'a
posé la question à ce moment là je dis
bah oui je sais d'où vient ma viande
je sais que c'est le producteur je sais
comment elle a été levée je sais même ce
qu'a mangé le cochon n'est pas de
maltraitance et après on se pose encore
d'autres questions se dit oui mais
aujourd'hui les gens mais habite plus
trop à la campagne mais plus en ville
sont prend les données de l'insee
plus de trois quarts de la population
habite dans les grandes villes donc
autant vous dire que les élevages ne
voit plus à la télé sur des reportages
qu'en vrai et si on prend une personne
qui habite à paris dans le xviième au 8e
étage mettra congélateur pour stocker sa
viande sur six mois ça aussi c'est pas
du tout pratique du coup on s'est posés
autour d'une table et on s'est dit mais
il ya sûrement quelque chose à faire
comment peut-on ramené peu l'élevage de
notre enfance tout en restant en ville
donc qu'est-ce qu'il faut apporter des
solutions au niveau de la logistique la
commercialisation et à ce moment là on
sortait tous les deux d'études en
création d'entreprise ce débat les shows
on monte nos startups
on y va on niveau sur le concept du quad
de schering se révèle bien comment ça
marche au crowdfunding nous allons
sélectionner des élevages de porcs 100%
plein air dans les régions de france pas
de pesticides ni d'engrais sur les
terres pas de médicaments ni 2e et pas
de maltraitance faite sur les animaux
quelques mois avant que le cochon arrive
à son terme
donc à son point final nous allons
proposer sur un site internet de là vous
consommateurs
vous allez pouvoir découvrir la race du
cochon les spécificités de ce dernier
donc un cochon c'est pas forcément rose
ça peut être noir marron blanc plus gros
moins gros et des poils et surtout qui
est derrière
l'éleveur comment les laisse les bêtes
ce qui leur donne à manger dans quelles
conditions ici cochon vous intéresse
vous allez pouvoir réserver précommander
votre part de cochon en fonction de
votre consommation
une fois que le cochon a été totalement
vendu il partira alors à ce moment à
l'abattoir sortie d'abattoirs nous
récupérons la carcasse nous débitons les
morceaux nous les mettons
individuellement sous vide on se
consulte ont constitué les caissettes et
après on les livre chez vous en camion
frigorifique donc vous obtenez une
traçabilité totalement transparente
en plus de ça nos sections des éleveurs
qui sont nés seraient engraisseurs ce
qui permet de même remonté à savoir
quitter le bar en équité la truie pour
vraiment déterminer l'origine de la race
mais en plus du crowdfunding il va
respecter les trois acteurs majeurs
d'une consommation durable tout d'abord
l'animal c'est des animaux qui sont
élevées en plein air pas de médicaments
ni gm aucune maltraitance est fait sur
le deuxième acteur c'est le producteur
avec ce système là et récupère une
majorité du prix final donc un commerce
équitable
ça lui facilite la gestion de son
exploitation et il fait son métier
éleveurs et ensuite après il est
beaucoup plus lille sur la
commercialisation et pour finir le
troisième acteur celui qui se trouve en
bout de chaîne c'est vous vous allez
pouvoir bien essayé d'une viande
artisanale goûteux boudeuse scène aux
qualités nutritionnelles reconnues
ça c'est pour la partie agréable mais en
plus de ça en passant par le
crowdfunding vous allez contribuer au
développement de petites et moyennes
exploitations au développement du
bien-être animal du plein air sans
médicaments ni ogm
il ya une meilleure rémunération du
producteur ce que vous consommez devient
aussi ce que vous protéger ça c'est pour
la partie utile mais le crumble shing ne
s'applique pas seulement aux ports il
s'explique aussi à d'autres animaux ils
sont tous ceux qui sont issus d'élevages
intensifs et surtout c'est des personnes
qui sont soucieuses de savoir ce qu'elle
mange qui était derrière leur
alimentation comment s'était fait ils
deviennent alors des consom'acteurs j'en
ai fini voilà merci
[Applaudissements]